[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 10 décembre
voici les titres de cette édition plus
de touristes moins de clientèle
d'affaires le confinement a placé le
monde de l'hôtellerie dans une situation
inconfortable
comment se porte le secteur actuellement
dans les yvelines reportage à saint
lambert des bois et à montigny le
bretonneux et invité philippe un
président de l'union des métiers des
industries de l'hôtellerie 78 pendant la
crise sanitaire les bénévoles de la
protection civile des yvelines sont en
renfort du samu plusieurs fois par
semaine des gardes sont assurés pour
faire des levées doutes concernant le
colis 19
nous avons pu suivre une équipe
mobilisée au départ du centre
hospitalier de versailles
et puis tout comme pour leurs amis du
football les rugbymen amateurs ont pu
reprendre les entraînements au sein de
leur club une pratique sans contact qui
est possible pour les majeurs comme pour
les mineurs réaction avec le rugby club
de plaisir à la fin de ce journal nous
irons voir également comment les
yvelinois ont décoré leur maison pour
les fêtes de fin d'année
l hôtellerie n'est pas concernés par les
fermetures administratives mais avec
déconfinement ans successifs et la mise
en place du télétravail
la fréquentation des établissements a
fortement baissé certains professionnels
ont choisi de fermer en novembre
d'autres ont choisi au contraire de
continuer leur activité malgré tout
exemple dans deux sites à montigny le
bretonneux et saint lambert des bois
avec mélanie poquet célia gars de son go
et nicolas d'ambri les clients profitent
à nouveau de l'auberge du manet depuis
le 23 novembre
depuis mars dernier l'établissement
accuse près d'un million d'euros de
perte de chiffre d'affaires on est sur
une occupation de trois ou quatre
chambres par jour quelquefois 6
mais encore une fois on va être là on va
exister être vivant par rapport à nos
clients les clients ce sont des
majoritairement des français puisque les
gens voyagent plus là on entre avec
beaucoup d'allemands en anglais des
italiens espagnols avec cette crise bien
sûr on n'a plus personne mais encore une
fois ça date pour le 2ème confinement
isabelle bianchi a choisi de proposer de
la vente à emporter quatre salariés
l'accompagnent dans l'activité à saint
lambert des bois aussi on a fait le
choix de rester ouvert en temps normal
80 % de la clientèle et professionnels
au mois de novembre le chiffre
d'affaires stagne autour des 10%
nous sommes restés ouverts m'a déjà pour
morale parce que fermer un établissement
on a notre restaurant qui a fermé en ce
moment je peux vous dire avoir un
établissement vide c'est d'une tristesse
incroyable
le personnel d'être démotivés et puis
surtout commence vraiment à souffrir
aussi de 7,2 se confie deuxième
confinement et on est restés ouverts bas
pour le peu qu'on faible ça paye un peu
de facture électrique un peu de factures
à droite à gauche bas c'est toujours ça
sylvie et jean françois goulard tiennent
la boutique depuis le mois de mars les
six employés sont en chômage partiel le
moment est plutôt à la patience pour que
cette célèbre phrase puisse reprendre
tout son sens et toujours dans cette
thématique philippin est avec mon
visioconférence le soir
président de l'umih 78 c'est l'union des
métiers des industries de l'hôtellerie
dans les yvelines
on l'a vu dans ce reportage certains
hôtels ont pris la décision de rester
ouverts malgré tout malgré la chute de
la clientèle
quelle est la tendance globale dans les
yvelines est ce que à l'instar de ses
hôtels que l'on vient de voir
est ce que beaucoup ont fait le choix de
rester ouverts ou au contraire beaucoup
d'établissements fermés alors au début
c'était un peu le stop and go au premier
confinement et ensuite pour le 2ème
effectivement les hôtels ont décidé de
rester ouverts pour certains sauf les
grosses structures ou aller aux porteurs
des hôtels de grosses capacités ont
décidé de fermer comme le trio palace
comme d'autres gros hôtels enfin mais
ils vont ils vont ouvrir pour les fêtes
de noël parce qu'ils ont une clientèle
plus des 6 nations charme des six
nations le week-end donc ces hôtels
l'avons pour ouvrir je pense aussi au
domaine de la corniche qui va ouvrir
pour les fêtes de noël sinon globalement
les hôtels restent ouverts mais avec des
taux d'occupation
complètement enfin ridicule
malheureusement pour eux ils soient
aujourd'hui à plus de touristes
étrangers c'est une clientèle française
même la clientèle d'affaires n'est pas
forcément au rendez vous puisque des
salariés sont davantage placée en
télétravail
aujourd'hui absolument la clientèle
corporate comme on dit dans le métier
n'est pas encore revenu même si ça
commence à un peu à revenir petit à
petit mais à des sociétés qui hésitent
évidemment puis qui privilégie le
télétravail puisque le gouvernement la
demande et donc c'est très compliqué de
rester ouverts pour des hôteliers alors
qu'on demande aux gens ne pas de se
déplacer c'est un peu un non sens malgré
cela les hôtels font entre 8 et 15 % de
taux d'occupation avec la clientèle de
personnes malheureusement quittés de
voir les des gens qui sont malades
c'est des gens de province qui est de
voir l'europe leur famille en région
parisienne d'aidés soignants des des
congrès qui est certains produits qui
sont maintenus en fin d mais la
situation est vraiment catastrophique
vous parliez de l'exemple du trianon
palace qui a fermé mais qui a été
privatisé notamment pour recevoir les
les miss france en tout cas les les
candidates pour le titre de miss france
et 2021
avant donc ce concours qui a lieu je
crois le 18 ou le 19 décembre
on l'a vu aussi au travers de ces deux
hôtels philippin l'un a perdu 1 million
d'euros de chiffre d'affaires depuis
mars
l'autre tourne autour des 10% du chiffre
d'affaires habituel
aujourd'hui on imagine qu'il ya des
établissements qui sont très fragilisées
à cause à cause de cette situation
oui je pense aux établissements qui
viennent d'être inquiets d'être
rachetées ou qui viennent de faire des
investissements conséquents ces
établissements là évidemment ils sont ce
sera plus difficile pour eux même si
c'est difficile pour tout le monde en
deux de façon assez c'est vraiment
catastrophique pour ses hôtels a
effectivement ce sera ce sera encore
plus compliqué et les aides sont les
bienvenues
d'ailleurs les professionnels de
l'hôtellerie estimait en novembre un
chiffre qui remonte à novembre que 47
mille emplois avaient déjà été supprimés
dans le monde de l'hôtellerie
il estime que d'ici la fin de l'année ce
pourrait être trente mille emplois
supplémentaires qui seraient supprimés
on imagine un l'état d'esprit est
vraiment à l'inquiétude aujourd'hui où
ce qu'il ya quand même de l'espoir et
une forme d'espoir il faut toujours
avoir l'espoir moi je préfère parler de
solution que plutôt que de parler de
chiffres en fait qu'il n'existe pas
finalement en ce moment les hôteliers
enfin dans le des 78 typhon ils essaient
de faire tout ce qu'ils peuvent à
l'exemple de deux exemples que vous
citez un des gens courageux qui font
tout ce qu'ils peuvent pour pour rester
ouvert
la situation par exemple à paris centre
est tout autre là par exemple
oui on va pouvoir s'attendre à des à des
défaillances maintenant c'est dans des
dans des coins plus reculés en province
on n'est pas logé à la même enseigne
je puis dire quelle que soit la région
non le chômage partiel a été prolongée
pour certains secteurs au moins jusqu'au
31 janvier notamment pour le tourisme
est-ce que c'est des garanties
suffisantes du gouvernement est ce qu'il
faut aller plus loin certains
professionnels demandent notamment à ce
que ce chômage partiel soit étendue au
moins jusqu'au printemps à lui toute
façon le chômage partiel il va suivre la
crise sanitaire je crois qu'on n'est pas
encore sorti et tant qu'on sera pas
encore sorti nous demanderons à
prolonger toutes ces mesures se serait
pas imminente
il faut quand même signaler pour les
auditeurs que dans l'hôtellerie
première aide depuis le mois de mars
sont intervenus qu'au mois d'octobre les
dix mille euros c'est à dire l'extension
du fonds de garantie du fonds de
solidarité a quitté 2500 euros avant et
qui est passé à dix mille euros pass
yeux et on peut pas payer un loyer
d'hôtel avec 1500 euros par mois donc
c'est pour ça que le gouvernement nous a
entendus et a aidé à augmenter ce fonds
de solidarité qui sera aussi ensuite
pour les mois suivants
basé sur qui sur 15% du chiffre
d'affaires si vous êtes à moins de 70%
de pertes ou 20% si vous êtes à +6 90%
de de perte de chiffre d'affaires le
président de la république à philippin
avait dit lors de sa dernière allocution
aux français qu' il pourrait partir en
vacances alors sous confinement ou pas
sous couvre-feu on va le savoir
le premier ministre jean castex
d'ailleurs s'exprime actuellement à
l'heure où je vous parle 18h09 s'il ya
du nouveau d'ailleurs je vous ne
manquerez pas de vous tenir informés est
ce que vous attendez beaucoup pour cette
cette période de noël où finalement vous
avez peut-être déjà fait une croix vous
regardez déjà plus loin sur l'année 2021
les professionnels sont fait une raison
un malheureusement bon comme je disais
il ya des hôtels la destination de
charme des hôtels 4 et 5 étoiles qui
vont essayer de récupérer un peu de
clients pour les fêtes mais si on
l'interdît ou aux familles de se
déplacer ça va être ça sera même plus la
peine d'ouvrir donc on compte
effectivement pour faire ça faisait le
compte sur noël mais on sait pas
d'illusion c'est pas ça qui va qui va
ramener des chiffres qui va qui va
masquer toutes ses pertes de l'année
2020 merci philippin pour ses réponses
je vous en prie je rappelle que vous
êtes le président de l'umih 78 immiscé
l'union des métiers et des industries de
l'hôtellerie
[Musique]
l'actualité c'est aussi bien sur
l'épidémie de kovy 19 le premier
ministre jean castex je lui disais il ya
un instant s'exprime ce soir autour de
la situation et pendant cette crise la
protection civile des yvelines effectué
des gardes en lien avec le samu
objectif faire des levées doute à
domicile auprès de personnes
potentiellement contaminées
une équipe de bénévoles était en poste
devant l'hôpital de versailles le centre
hospitalier de versailles vendredi
dernier le 4 décembre avec justin
brasier nous l'avons suivi le temps
d'une soirée des gardes opérées dans le
cadre de lakovic 19 pour lever les
doutes de contamination pour cette
mission la protection civile des
yvelines travail avec l'hôpital de
versailles une équipe et postés devant
l'établissement pour réagir au plus vite
en cas d'appel
il est 22h40 la première alerte tombe le
binôme d'astreinte est envoyé au
domicile d'une personne présentant des
signes de covile 19
les bénévoles s'équipent en conséquence
pour se protéger on s'équipe et après on
rentre chez la personne du don comme une
combinaison un calot un masque des gants
oui bonjour madame c des secours est ce
que vous pourriez venir nous ouvrir
votre pavillon on est juste devant sur
place les secouristes font un premier
bilan
les informations sont transmises au samu
un processus qui permet d'adapter la
prise en charge de la victime
les bouchons c'est la protection civile
d'une nouvelle reconnaissance c'est pour
une transmission bilan et d'yvon faire
un premier bilan secouriste ils vont
transmettre au niveau de la régulation
médicale du samu etc la régulation
médicale qui décidera de l'avenir de la
victime soit on la laisse sur place soit
il ya un moyen spécialisés qui vient ça
peut être une ambulance privée
ça peut être les sapeurs pompiers comme
le smur qui vient médicalisé
l'intervention les médecins du samu a
préféré appeler les pompiers directement
pour transporter là la victime à
l'hôpital
donc elle sera emporté sur en fonction
de ce que sa et six sur l'hôpital
du secteur et enfin de confirmer ou pas
la levée de doute commis l'équipe
restera avec la victime jusqu'à
l'arrivée des pompiers quelques minutes
plus tard après l'intervention
l'ensemble du matériel et désinfecter
les conflits ont pris le relais oui
exactement nous coulons gratte
déshabillez vous mettre dans un sac dans
une
dans un carton dasri et on va retourner
aux abus une trentaine de gardes ont été
réalisés lors du premier confinement
depuis le 30 octobre une vingtaine de
gardes ont déjà été opérées et face à
cette épidémie de kobe 19 le lion's club
ile de france ouest qui regroupe les
yvelines les hauts-de seine et le val
d'oise a mis en place une plate forme
téléphonique elle est mise en place pour
aider les particuliers les associations
ou encore les établissements sociaux et
les centres de soins
l'idée offrir un appui de la part de ses
membres faire des courses aller chercher
des médicaments apporter un soutien
moral pour une personne isolée aider
financièrement les centres de soins la
plateforme est ouvert du lundi au samedi
de 9h à 20h joignable au numéro qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
en bref c'est officiel le nouveau marché
des clayes sous bois ouvrira le 7
janvier prochain le bâtiment flambant
neuf est située juste en face de
l'ancienne halle coût total près de 5
millions d'euros et les travaux entamés
en 2018 était terminé mais l'ouverture
du lieu a été retardé en fonctions en
raison d'un problème sur les portes
coupe-feu finalement une commission
sécurité passé aujourd'hui a donné son
aval
une fois la nouvelle halle en fonction
l'ancien marché sera détruit pour
laisser place à un programme immobilier
de 35 logements le sport depuis quelques
semaines les mineurs ont pu reprendre la
pratique en club et en extérieur en ce
qui concerne le rugby et le football
elle est majeure aussi ont été autorisé
à s'entraîner à nouveau dans une
pratique sans contact le week-end
dernier le rugby-club de plaisir a donc
repris le chemin des terrains
le reportage de sebia 400 go
le rugby-club de plaisir a repris ses
entraînements pour les enfants il n'y a
plus d'une semaine et pour les seniors
il y a quelques jours le jeu au pied est
l'un des exercices accepté du stade 3
par la fédération de rugby le stade iii
donc c'est un stade avec distanciation
des couloirs les joueurs se peuvent se
faire des passes en ayant d'imparables
une désaffection des équipements et puis
bien sûr quand ils arrivent ils ont des
seins vexant des mains et puis nous on
prend aussi la température airbus les
vestiaires ne sont pas utilisés les
séances ont aussi été réduite de 45
minutes au lieu d'une heure et demie
pour éviter les croisements entre les
joueurs
les parents ne peuvent plus accompagné
leurs enfants jusqu'aux stades quant au
sac ils sont rangés sur le côté et bien
espacées au niveau des entraînements
plus aucun contact
il faut donc pour les entraîneurs
trouver des solutions ils sont encore
petits donc on leur montre l'endroit où
ils doivent se tenir
pour ça on est obligées de mettre
beaucoup de plo chacun espacé d'entre 2
et 3 m pour vraiment qui sert autres qui
se tiennent éloignés le maximum des
adaptations nécessaires pour le bon
maintien des règles sanitaires
c'est différent je préférais quand y
avait les matches je veux qu'on pouvait
bien se plaquer mais bon là on peut plus
on a fait un entraînement avec des
conflits raison des comptes payants est
dégoupillée loin et on voit ça change de
d'habitude parce qu'on fait moi le
contact la plupart des exercices en les
modifiant un petit peu pour garder plus
de distance qui change c'est que voilà
on fait surtout pas de matelas la santé
oms c'est un peu dommage pour les petits
mais bon c'est non pas longtemps on
retrouvera les rugbys normal donc ça va
allez vous y croyez vous bien sûr je
suis confiant et j'espère surtout les
compétitions devraient reprendre au mois
de janvier si les conditions sanitaires
le permettent un peu de couleur à
présent dans ce journal avec cette
fresque est réalisé en ce moment à
montigny le bretonneux l'artiste fkdl
spécialisée dans le street art l'a peint
sur le mur de la vélostation de saint
quentin en yvelines
les usagers qui se rendent à la gare par
ce couloir pourront la voir
il s'agit d'une commande de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines fkdl avait déjà réalisé pour la
collectivité
une oeuvre autour du golfe et de la
ryder cup 2018 qui est également exposé
dans ce couloir entre la gare et la
vélostation
une fresque cette fois ci autour de
l'univers du vélo avec des personnages
notamment féminins et des couleurs pop
signature de l'artiste les propos
recueillis par patrick jacques de
dixmude vous nous avez une idée voilà je
vais reproduire ce que cette petite
maquette que j'ai réalisé c'est une
maquette sur l'ordi un faux pas c'est
toujours mieux en vrai et voilà pour
cette occasion je vais faire un énorme
vélo qui va sortir un peu du fond coloré
et puis je voulais quelque chose qui
soit assez à la fois chauds et les plus
tôt plutôt sympa pour pour la ville et
puis surtout à la place de ces panneaux
gris qui était existants et puis après
les couleurs en peinture les couleurs en
lumière qui dit esprit noël dit
forcément illuminations comme chaque
année vous croiserez dans les rues et
des maisons décorées de sapins de rennes
pourquoi pas et aussi de guirlandes en
toujours certaines communes comme la
verrière ont même lancé des concours
pour leurs habitants mélanie poké et
bixente mais rien senti steban que
serait noël sans ces maisons parsemaient
de guirlandes et autres décorations
scintillantes
certaines familles ont l'habitude de
revêtir leurs demeures de belles parures
au plus grand bonheur des passants le
moyen de se mesurer au concours des plus
belles décorations de noël
une première à la verrière depuis
quelques années déjà on attendait ce
concours avec impatience et dès qu'on a
eu le flyer dans la boîte aux lettres on
a été super content que ce soit lancée
cette année sur la verrière et on s'est
empressé de
de répondre à la mairie et de dire que
c'était une super initiative
l'occasion de passer de bons moments
pour les familles à choisir les
différents ornements ainsi que leur
disposition comment s'est installée
c'était marrant c'est qu'on y avait un
concours on a vu que ont il y avait le
concours du coup du coup on a commencé à
décorer tweet c'est surtout que ça
éclaire un petit peu dans tous les sens
et c'est aussi ça l'esprit de noël pour
nous à quelques kilomètres de là une
autre maison est prête et étincelante un
hobby de longue date devenu une habitude
même si aucun concours n'a lieu cette
année sauf une dizaine d'années on a
commencé avec le concours des maisons
décorées de coignières et puis on s'est
pris au jeu tous les ans rom est simple
chaque année comme vous le voyez il ya
le sapin il ya mon élevage de rennes
taillé dans du polystyrène ya les les
guirlandes lumineuses des bolets et puis
on en ajoute une ou deux tous les ans
donc au début on est parti avec une
décoration très pauvres qui au fil du
temps brrr ça ça monte en puissance
une mise en place qui a pris plusieurs
jours des petites touches personnelles
ont même été ajoutée pour parfaire le
décor les rênes le père noël et la luge
sont faits maison
jamais un peu d'animation dans le
quartier ce qui nous amuse le plus c'est
de voir les voitures qui ralentissent
certaines s'arrêtent regardent y en a
qui viennent jusque au portail e à la
verrière un jury passe évaluer les
décorations du 14 au 18 décembre
une maison un appartement et un magasin
se verront chacun décerner une
récompense mais le concours n'est pas
nécessaire pour certains cela permet
d'égayer une période délicate en
ravivant l'esprit de noël
voilà pour l'actualité locale avant de
refermer ce journal vous le saviez 1
emmanuel macron avait fixé le cap
repassé sous la barre des 5000
contamination par jour aux copies de 19
pour permettre la levée du confinement
le 15 décembre un objectif qui ne sera
vraisemblablement pas atteint mardi et
jean castex s'exprime toujours
actuellement 18h19 autour de cette
actualité et nous venons de l'apprendre
le confinement sera remplacé à partir du
15 décembre par un couvre-feu un couvre
feu qui sera assez large effectif
de 20h à 6h du matin une seule exception
la nuit du 24 décembre pour permettre
aux français est d'aller fêter noël en
famille en revanche contrairement à ce
qui avait été annoncé par emmanuel
macron il n'y aura pas de dérogations
possibles pour la nuit de la saint
sylvestre la nuit du 31 décembre
donc vous ne pourrez pas à fêter le
nouvel an dans des conditions normales
autre annonce très importante à retenir
les cinémas les théâtres et les musées
qui devait rouvrir normalement si la
situation sanitaire le permettait le 15
décembre resteront fermés et ce pour une
durée minimum de trois semaines
un point sera fait par le gouvernement
pour voir si les chiffres du coït 19
s'améliore voilà ce que l'on pouvait
vous dire et nous reviendrons bien sûr
sur toutes ces annonces les annonces
principal à retenir dans notre édition
de demain vendredi dans le journal
présenté par eléonore sinoquet voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité dans un instant vous avez
rendez vous avec si on rentrait c'est
l'émission qui vous occupe à domicile
pendant cette période de confinement les
belles soirées avec tv 78
[Musique]